Bonjour allez vous bien ? Moi ça va
Ecoutez aujourd'hui je fais cette vidéo totalement à l'improviste
Parce-que il s'est passé un truc qui n'était pas prévu,
Hier j'ai tourné deux vidéos
Donc l'une sur un jeu où c'était une fête foraine, et en fait, j'me suis pas amusé à la tourner
C'est le genre de jeu sur lequel j'aurai fait des vidéos avant,
et il se trouve qu'en fait, ça m'amuse plus
En fait j'ai tourné.. J'me suis moyennement amusé..
Et au montage c'était désastreux, tu peux rien en tirer
Les gens vont vraiment pas rire, et pas passer de bon moment devant la vidéo
Parce que j'ai moi-même pas passé un bon moment quand je jouais à ce jeu,
Et en fait c'est la première fois en 6 ans que ça m'arrive, c'est à dire
Faire ce que je faisais tous les jours pendant très longtemps,
Mais d'un coup ça m'amuse plus
Et en fait, j'ai trouvé pourquoi j'avais ce problème,
C'est que, dernièrement, j'ai fait des vidéos et même des projets
Dans lesquels je me suis éclaté comme jamais
Y'a eu le clip avec Maxenss,
Y'a eu la vidéo avec Bigflo et Oli,
Y'a eu la vidéo avec McFly, Carlito et Natoo,
Et ce sont des vidéos que vous avez particulièrement aimés
Et ce sont des vidéos que j'ai particulièrement aimé faire moi aussi
Donc en fait y'a vraiment un lien entre le plaisir que je prends sur le tournage
et le plaisir que vous avez en les regardant, c'est totalement proportionnel
Plus que jamais, et ces deux dernières semaines me l'ont montré,
J'ai juste envie de faire ce que j'aime sur youtube et..
sur un an.. c'est pas ce que j'ai fait, en fait
Je me suis rappelé pourquoi j'avais commencé youtube, c'était pour faire des vidéos,
à l'époque c'était avec mes potes du lycée,
En fait c'était pour délirer à plusieurs, j'ai commencé les vidéos pour délirer à plusieurs,
Pour m'amuser à plusieurs, et puis, au bout d'un moment je me suis très vite rendu compte
Qu'à l'époque pour marcher sur youtube il fallait faire du contenu fréquemment
Il fallait sortir des vidéos souvent, peu importe les vidéos
... Y Fallait en sortir !
Donc j'suis rentré dans ce truc là de faire plusieurs vidéos par semaine
Parce qu'il fallait faire ça pour que ta chaîne et tes vidéos soient mise en avant
Et on cherchait tous à être mis en avant
Sans se dire que c'est en faisant de bonnes vidéos qu'on serait mis en avant
Et pas en faisant X nombre de vidéos par semaine
Pour être le plus clair possible en gros, quand tu t'imposes un rythme de vidéos par semaine,
Tu vas faire deux vidéos qui vont vraiment te plaire, que tu vas apprécier,
Et tu vas faire une ou deux vidéos, que je dirais de transition
C'est à dire tu sais que c'est pas ouf, mais tu le fais quand même
Parce que tu tiens à mettre tes 4 vidéos en ligne par semaine,
Et à faire plus de vues que les autres
Et ce système là j'en ai marre, je veux plus procéder comme ça,
J'veux être fier de chaque putain de vidéo que je mets en ligne sur ma chaîne,
Sans penser aux stats, sans penser aux abonnés,
Juste faire du contenu que j'aime faire
Que j'aime présenter aux gens
Et du coup c'est forcément un peu plus de vidéos à plusieurs,
Parce que je trouve que tu partages plus de choses dans les vidéos à plusieurs que dans les vidéos seul,
Et dans les vidéos seul c'est un peu plus de trucs originaux
ou alors des trucs sur les jeux comme actuellement mais..
... quand t'aimes VRAIMENT le jeu
Pas quand tu te dis : Ah ouais ça c'est un peu drôle allez on va faire ça t'façon faut que je fasse ma vidéo du jour
Je veux plus procéder de cette manière là
C'est de cette manière là que je marche depuis 6 ans
C'est en m'imposant 4 vidéos par semaine quitte à ce qu'il y ait des vidéos qui soient pas ouf
Et je sais qu'elles sont pas ouf
Et au tournage, je me force à faire semblant d'aimer ce que je suis en train de faire
Alors que j'aime pas plus que ça,
Et je trouve ça nul à la longue de faire ça
Et j'pense que, avec le chemin que j'ai parcouru aujourd'hui je peux faire que c'que j'aime
Et m'éviter ces espèces de "vidéos de transition
ça veut pas dire plus de jeu vidéo attention c'est pas ce que je dis
Mais ça veut dire, plus de vidéos où, je fais semblant
J'espère que c'est clair.. Je sais pas si c'est clair.. Je suis nul pour expliquer, c'est terrible ! *hihi*
Et j'pense que c'est un peu compréhensible..
J'me gratte la barbichette
Quand je pars en vacances, et la semaine prochaine je pars une semaine au Canada avec Clément on va faire des vidéos là-bas
Je vais prolonger mon voyage d'une semaine là-bas,
Pour avoir une vraie semaine de vacances, où je fais pas de vidéos
Quand je pars habituellement en vacances la semaine d'avant je prépare 8 vidéos aulieu de 4
Je dois en tourner 8 en 5 jours
Et.. En fait c'est totalement impossible de trouver, en 4-5 jours,
8 idées de vidéos biens, et surtout,
De pouvoir le faire, ce n'est techniquement pas possible
Et là je suis dans cette situation où j'avais mon programme : La semaine prochaine je pars au Canada,
Et peut-être que, du coup, y'aura qu'une vidéo qui sera mise en ligne
Peut-être les 4 que je voulais mettre en ligne
Si j'y arrive, si j'ai les idées et si ça me plaît, mais
Si j'ai pas les idées,
Et bah je veux pas faire de trucs nuls
Histoire d'avoir 4 vidéos à mettre en ligne
Je veux que quand je mets une vidéo en ligne, j'en sois fier
Que moi-même, j'ai pas honte en la regardant,
Parce-que y'a des vidéos où.. quand je les regarde ou quelqu'un la regarde à côté de moi j'suis pas bien
Et ça montre qu'il y a un vrai problème avec ces vidéos là, c'est que j'en suis pas fier
Jusqu'à me sentir mal à l'aise quand quelqu'un la regarde à côté de moi c'est grave quand même
En m'imposant ce putain de rythme de 4 vidéos par semaine j'arrive pas à être fier de tout ce que je sors
Et ça me plaît pas du tout
Peut-être que je suis de moins en moins indulgent avec moi-même et c'est normal
à partir d'aujourd'hui je mettrais peut-être plus 4 vidéos en ligne par semaine
Je ferai p't'être moins de vues
Je gagnerai p't'être  moins d'abonnés
Mais je serai fier de ce que je ferai
Voilà
Ca fait du bien! *rire de sagouin*
Les vues vont forcément baisser, si je fais moins de vidéos,
Et quand on est youtuber psychologiquement voir ses vues baisser je trouve que c'est dur,
Tu te dis : "merde, putain j'ai toujours fait.. moi je sais pas je fais 90 millions de vues par mois,
Bah là je ferai, soixante
Ou soixante-dix j'en sais rien ou quarante j'en sais rien
Mais putain.. Au moins je serai hyper bien dans mes baskets
C'est ce que je veux dans ma vie en fait
C'est être hyper bien dans mes baskets quitte à faire moins de vues c'est pas grave
Mais à faire du contenu dont j'suis fier
Je serai de bonne humeur en me levant
Je serai de bonne humeur en me levant et j'aimerai encore plus ma vie
Et c'est ça que je veux aujourd'hui
Donc ne soyez pas surpris dans les semaines à venir, ça m'a fait du bien de vous parler de ça
C'est pas facile, j'espère que vous serez pas déçus, que vous m'en voudrez pas ou quoi
ça va peut-être en décevoir certains, mais franchement c'est pour mon bien et c'est aussi pour votre bien
Pour que chaque vidéo soit vraiment cool
ça veut pas dire que y'aura qu'une ou deux vidéos par semaine, pas du tout
Y'aura peut-être des fois 4 vidéos comme actuellement
Et si y'en a que deux bah ce sera deux de moins qu'habituellement
Mais au moins ce sera deux vidéos dont je serai fier et qui seront vraiment cools
C'est un gros changement psychologiquement, et c'est positif
Je sais pas si vous pouvez vous en rendre compte,
Mais voilà, être fier de ce que tu mets en ligne, ne pas avoir trop de pression, être prêt à voir tes stats baisser mais t'en battre les couilles,
Parce que ce que tu veux c'est continuer à kiffer ton métier, continuer à faire kiffer les gens,
Et continuer à te faire kiffer toi-même
Les vidéos n'en seront que meilleures, et même si les stats n'en sont que moins bonnes, je m'en fou
Je veux faire ce que j'aime.. et j'ai la chance de pouvoir faire ce que j'aime
Donc autant procéder comme ça et pas autrement..
Et voilà
Allez à bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo, reposez vous bien pendant les vacances,
Bon courage pour le taff si y'en a qui taffent et puis
J'espère que les prochaines vidéos, vous en faites pas j'aurai de l'énergie
C'est juste qu'aujourd'hui, se prendre la réalité en face et s'apercevoir qu'on est plus comme avant
Et qu'on a envie de nouvelles choses et de prendre le courage de changer sa manière de faire
Quitte à ce que ça déplaise aux gens
Quitte à ce qu'on marche moins bien
C'est pas facile mais c'était important que je le fasse
C'est fait ! à bientôt, et j'espère que les prochaines vidéos VOUS PLAIRONT ! *salto arrière*
Aurevoir